when the first germanic settlers from
northwestern europe arrived in britain
they were officially landing in the
province of britannia
one of the far flung corners of the
roman empire
but they would not have found there the
dynamic and prosperous province of
hadrian's day
no
these were the waning decades of roman
rule
and it was in this crucible of decline
that england would be forged
before we dive into these final years
let's briefly recap the rise and fall of
roman britain
prior to the roman conquest britain was
inhabited by a variety of tribes
speaking dialects of the celtic family
of languages
these dialects are referred to by
linguists as britonic
and britonic is the ancestor of the
later celtic languages we know of
surviving today in britain as welsh and
cornish and in brittany as breton
the britonic peoples or britons
practiced agriculture and engaged in
trade with each other and with the roman
world particularly in the south east
which had always been open to contacts
with the continent
this openness to the continent
foreshadowed the essential divide
between the trade oriented south and
east and the more pastorally oriented
north and west of britain
some of these tribal groupings were
large and powerful and their leaders
sometimes lived in large hill forts
particularly in the south and west
though these were not nearly as well
developed as the hill forts of the
continental celtic speakers whom julius
caesar confronted during his campaigns
and gaul in the 50s bc
the tribes in britain in some cases had
close ties to the tribes in gaul and it
was partly in an effort to force stall
military aid to the gaulish tribes that
caesar conducted exploratory campaigns
in britain in 55 and 54 bc
neither campaign amounted to much
and it was another century before the
romans decided to get serious about
conquering britain
in 44 a.d the emperor claudius was
seeking a way to burnish his lackluster
military reputation
so he ordered a major expedition to
britain and he accompanied the invasion
himself
though he was no soldier and took no
part in the actual fighting
the romans rather rapidly conquered the
various tribes of southern britain who
were not able to unite
particularly as many tribes differed on
whether to collaborate with the romans
or resist them
having asserted control the romans then
established villa-based agriculture in
the fertile and arable plains of the
south and east of britain which
prospered for centuries
the hillier north and west of britain
was better suited to grazing and
pastoral farming
but the romans were also forced to
install an extensive military
infrastructure in these regions to hold
down their more rebellious inhabitants
this geographical divide is still a
feature of life in britain today
even though it has been a long time
since agriculture dominated the british
economy
the britons of the lowlands south and
east were rather quickly converted to a
roman way of life
with bouts of periodic resistance
the most serious came when boudicca the
queen of the iceni revolted in 61 a.d
due to mistreatment by roman imperial
officials
it was a close run thing for roman rule
in britain and boudicca was able to sack
and burn the roman commercial settlement
at londinium
the layer of ash from the fire she
started is still visible in the ground
her revolt was ultimately suppressed
however and order in the southeast was
restored
but the north and west required a
constant military presence
so britain was always brimming with
soldiers
at least on the fringes of roman ruled
territory
in the north the romans faced the
hostile caledonians
and they saw less of an advantage in
investing in the troops required to hold
the rugged lands of what is now northern
england and scotland
so they decided to draw a kind of stone
line in the sand
by building what we know as hadrian's
wall
a less formidable barrier known as the
antonine wall was built a few decades
later some hundred miles to the north
but swiftly abandoned
hadrian's wall represented the northern
lemays or limit of the roman empire
the wall did not act as an impermeable
barrier it was more of a point of
contact and trade and people flowed
freely back and forth across the wall
still this was a heavily militarized
zone
archaeologists have found extensive
evidence of the long settlement of the
legions along the wall
hadrian's wall is the most visible
reminder of the roman presence in
britain
but it really didn't create a meaningful
border beyond the roman period and in
particular it would not become the
border between england and scotland
roman towns and cities quickly developed
in the territory south of the wall
as in many other roman provinces these
towns were constructed on a grid pattern
with many of the amenities that romans
would have come to expect in their
italian homeland
there would be temples of course
but also a forum area for conducting
public business and trade and an arena
for public games
public bath houses were a must
the natural springs at aqua soules
which we know today as the town of bath
were famous even outside of britain
there were also small manufacturing
businesses that emerged in the towns
taking advantage of the roman trade
networks
the most important trading center in
roman britain was londinium today london
on the thames river
londinium had already been used as a
port by the britons before the romans
arrived
the other important centers in britain
were york
chester and lincoln
the roman road system connected all
these settlements but in some cases the
roads were built on existing native
trackways
the inhabitants of britain knew their
own landscape and made prudent decisions
about how to take advantage of the
topography to create the most efficient
routes across the countryside
the roman engineers in many cases had no
desire to tamper with what was not
broken
for example the famous wattling street
which runs from dover in the southeast
to rockster in the northwest
was built on an existing route from the
pre-roman era
later british transportation engineers
could not improve much upon this earlier
work and it is still the basis for parts
of the roads known as the a2 and the a5
and outside of the major population
centers much of britain carried on as it
always had
in agriculture for example traditional
field systems and practices continued
we know from archaeology that some field
patterns had already existed for
thousands of years by the time the
romans came
these were some of the same patterns
that would persist through the period of
germanic settlement as well
there was a long tradition in the
countryside that waves of newcomers did
not really do much to alter
but there were some very distinctly
roman enclaves in the midst of this
landscape
in the prosperous south and east
villa life on the italian model with
estates supported by slave labor
flourished for several centuries
these villas could be quite large
but they vary considerably in size and
many of their owners were probably
members of the existing native elite who
had simply adopted a roman lifestyle
there were clearly some villas that
belonged to people of middling rank
one villa from verulamium modern saint
albans
boasted prefab mosaics
a far cheaper alternative to the
customized mosaics that would have
graced the villas of the truly wealthy
in other words this was a stratified
society with a flourishing economy that
could support the kind of social
aspirations that the villa owners in
verulamium were engaged in
in addition to agriculture and small
manufacturing
britain was also renowned for its
extractive industries particularly the
tin mining of the southwest
cornwall had been a source of tin for
the mediterranean as far back as the
second millennium bc
and the romans further developed the
potential of the tin mines
the remains of roman mining operations
are still quite visible in the landscape
of this part of britain
economically then roman britain did well
for the first two centuries or so
it was obviously on the periphery of the
roman empire but it was very much
integrated within it through networks of
trade through the military and through
imperial taxation
during this time
christianity spread to britain probably
at some point during the third century
which was a period of explosive growth
in christianity throughout the empire
the new faith was likely confined to the
urban areas and the roman villas
many christian artifacts have been found
in these places
this is going to be very important going
forward because when the germanic
settlers arrived they were going to find
a mixed religious landscape there was
certainly plenty of christian worship in
the romanized areas
but there was also quite a bit of pagan
practice and probably both roman cults
and pre-existing native cults were being
observed especially in the countryside
the cultural prestige of the later pagan
germanic settlers
may have led to the extinction of much
of the christian worship that the romans
had established
but christianity was not totally wiped
out
and it was actually doing well in the
north and west
so there was at least a seed from which
christianity could regrow
even if it required a major graft from
both the continent and ireland in order
to do so
linguistically the situation in roman
britain was similarly mixed
in the towns in particular there was
probably a great deal of bilingualism
we have a large number of curse tablets
that survive from aqua sulis these are
inscriptions on slate tablets that were
ritually deposited in the waters there
as a way of communicating with the gods
and they often included curses against
someone's enemies
saturninus stole my cloak the bastard
etc
these were in latin
but we know that britonic languages also
continue to be spoken there are place
names that survive into the anglo-saxon
times that are brotonic in origin
and while we cannot always tell how old
these names are
they certainly indicate some degree of
linguistic continuity
the situation in britain thus offers an
interesting contrast to gaul
where the celtic language spoken there
at the time of the roman conquest known
as gaulish seems to have gone completely
out of use
britain was never as thoroughly
romanized as gaul so when the germanic
settlers arrived in britain they were in
a different situation from say the
franks who settled in gaul
culturally the franks were largely
absorbed by the gallow romans
but in britain as we will see
it was the other way around
so now that we've described roman
britain at its height
we need to talk about what happened to
cause its decline
scholars don't agree on exactly when the
romano-british economy started to
decline
some put the downturn in the late 3rd
century some in the early fourth
but one thing is clear
the trajectory of the economy was
downward beginning at some point round
about 300 or so
how do we know this
the archaeological record tells the tale
previously residents of britain had had
access to manufactured goods from all
over the roman empire this was part of
the integration into roman life that had
resulted from the conquest
there was a particularly active trade in
pottery as there were extensive ceramic
manufacturing centers in southern gaul
and the goods they produced were shipped
up the rhone river and then down the sen
once they were shipped to britain
there were even pots from as far away as
north africa which was another major
center of ceramic production
but there were also local ceramic
manufacturers in britain that produced
lower quality but still quite
serviceable pottery so people had a
choice of price ranges they could even
buy different kinds of pots for
different uses the way a modern family
might buy their everyday china from one
source and their fine china from another
this kind of market differentiation is
the sign of a thriving economy
but in the fourth century we start to
see a decline in manufacturing and by
the 5th century trade from the continent
has dried up particularly in the south
and east which had previously been the
region that was most open to trade with
the rest of the empire
to give one tangible example of this
decline
consider this
wheel thrown pottery was no longer
widely made in britain by the 5th
century and would not be produced again
in large quantities for hundreds of
years
wheel thrown pots are far superior to
hand-formed pots they are more regular
in shape more stable and less prone to
defects and they are easier to mass
produce
if people in the ancient world had
access to them they always opted for
them
but they require specialized tools and
expert potters to produce them at a
commercially viable scale
so the decline of their production tells
us that the market for these items had
simply dried up and with it an entire
industry had downshifted to a more
rudimentary form
think about what a step backward that
must have been to suddenly find yourself
living in a world where everyday objects
you once took for granted had become
extremely rare
archaeology can tell us other quite
worrisome things about how the economy
was doing
for one thing there is evidence that
people in britain were scavenging among
ruins for anything usable they could
find especially manufactured metal goods
like nails and other hardware
this tells us that the building industry
had basically shut down as had ancillary
businesses like iron forging
today one metric that economists use to
tell how well the economy is thriving is
the level of steel production because
it's a proxy for all sorts of other
things that the economy makes like cars
appliances and heavy manufacturing
machines
iron forging was the same kind of
indicator in the ancient world
archaeologists have noted that the level
of iron slag being produced at the end
of the roman empire declined sharply the
demand for iron had simply collapsed
in britain we see this collapse in
another very interesting way in the
archaeological record
normally archaeologists use changing
fashions in jewelry and other articles
of dress and adornment to establish the
date of a find
this works because fashions do tend to
shift
we can tell the difference between a
kind of broach that was popular in the
first century from one that was popular
in the second century
but this process of relative dating gets
very difficult in late roman britain
because in addition to scavenging for
usable metal in ruins
people were also
passing down heirlooms
rather than changing their fashions in
jewelry with the same regularity as
before
and again this was a sign that people
were clinging rather desperately to what
they had
because they could not easily replace
these objects
so what caused this economic collapse
the reason this question is so difficult
to answer is because there was a great
deal of political instability in this
period
and it's hard to say whether the
economic troubles caused the political
instability
or the other way around it is certainly
true that political instability is bad
for business
quite apart from the disruption to trade
caused by military threats
if people are worried about their safety
they're going to take fewer economic
risks so that will depress demand all by
itself
but it's also true that people whose
livelihood is under threat are far more
likely to become disgruntled with the
powers than be
scholars disagree among themselves about
what caused what
but something bad was clearly happening
in late roman britain
we've sketched the downturn in the
economy
let's talk now about the political
crisis
the roman empire generally was engulfed
in this time by the so-called third
century crisis
during this period rome was rocked by
repeated political upheavals and by
military threats on its borders and
during the middle third of the century
the empire literally broke apart into
three pieces
despite its distance from rome
britain was at many times center stage
during the crisis
and the fragmentation of the empire had
a direct impact on the integrity of
britain's defenses against its barbarian
enemies
who were coming not just from north of
hadrian's wall but also from along the
southern coasts where waves of barbarian
raiders and dislocated peoples had begun
to land
very importantly for our story
in 286 a roman naval commander named
carousias took advantage of the chaos
and briefly took control of britain
declaring himself emperor there
during his brief reign he called in
friesians and saxons to help shore up
the defenses of the island along the
southeastern coast
that section of coast later became known
as the saxon shore though historians are
not sure whether this was because saxons
had been called in to defend it or
because saxons were the people the shore
needed to be defended against
there could be a little bit of
retrospective branding going on here
because saxons would later raid along
the coast and then settle in britain
but the name conveys a basic truth the
enemies of rome were not slow to take
advantage of these internal squabbles
with britain often playing a starring
role
the father of emperor constantine
constantius the first having deposed the
imposter carousias
was still serving in britain when he was
elevated to the purple by his troops
whereupon he left for the continent and
his imperial destiny
a path that many later would-be usurpers
would tread
but let's go back to carousias's
friesians and saxons
who were they
it is helpful here i think to make a
quick tour of the barbarian landscape of
northwestern europe
keep in mind that the names of peoples
that i am going to cite are extremely
vague indications of what we might think
of as ethnicity
ethnic identity was very fluid in this
period
peoples on the move often swept up
additional followers as they went along
and people could and did switch cultural
allegiance quite readily
but that said we need at least some
indication of who was on the board
so here goes
the most important barbarians for our
purposes are the residents of the
coastal regions of northwestern europe
moving north from roman gaul there were
the friesians
mostly in what is now belgium and the
netherlands
continuing north and east along the
coast into today's germany we find the
saxons and a bit further east the angles
whose territory extended north into what
is now denmark
these are going to be the most important
groups who sent settlers to britain
they would have all spoken closely
related dialects of the western branch
of the germanic family of languages
and likely these groups would have been
able to communicate with each other
but there is another group of people we
need to introduce
not because they will settle in britain
in large numbers but because they will
end up dominating northwestern europe
after the fall of rome namely the franks
during the later fourth century the
franks had begun infiltrating northern
gaul and over the course of the fifth
century they slowly but surely hollowed
out the roman administration in gaul
until
in 486 the last roman imperial official
siagrius was defeated at the battle of
swassel by clovis the first acknowledged
king of the franks
there is some controversy over exactly
how the roman government in britain
responded to the threat from
northwestern europe
but the saxon shore played an
increasingly important role in the
defensive strategy of the island with
forts built along the southeast coast
most of the time the forts were adequate
for repelling small nuisance raids
but the so-called barbarian conspiracy
in 367
represented the most serious threat to
roman rule since boudicca's revolt
in that year britain was attacked
virtually simultaneously by several
barbarian peoples
the scotty from ireland the picts from
scotland and the atacadi the franks and
the saxons from northwestern europe
it is hard to grasp exactly how these
various tribes were able to coordinate
their activities but somehow they must
have done so
because the defensive resources even of
the heavily militarized province of
britain
were overwhelmed
to make matters worse the disorder
occasioned by the raids led many roman
soldiers in britain to desert and join
in the plundering
the reason this event matters for our
purposes is that we see here one
inflection point in the relationship
between the germanic peoples and the
island of britain
after this period
contact between britain and these
peoples seems to have increased
there are signs that there had been a
germanic presence in britain already for
a considerable period even before the
barbarian conspiracy
from the 3rd century the romans had
begun enlisting germans into the legions
at an accelerated rate in an attempt to
co-opt them
there were germans stationed in such
far-flung regions of the empire as egypt
and syria
this dynamic later caused more germans
to want to enter roman territory
word got back to the soldiers relatives
beyond the borders and migrations
resulted
something similar may have happened with
german soldiers stationed with the roman
legions in britain
the savior of roman britain at the time
of the barbarian conspiracy was the
father of the future roman emperor
theodosius the great
also named theodosius
who arrived in 368 and was able to
stabilize the situation
but 15 years later when the roman empire
was still reeling from the disastrous
defeat and death of the eastern emperor
valens at the battle of adrian opal in
378
a roman general named magnus maximus
rebelled against emperor gratian and
took several legions with him out of
britain to the continent to pursue his
ultimately unsuccessful claim to the
imperial throne
he was never replaced with a commander
of equivalent stature
progressively britain was being denuded
of its military strength
and its borders were becoming more
porous
and as the situation for the roman
administration became increasingly
desperate
britain slipped farther and farther down
on the priority list
the details of the roman withdrawal from
britain are murky but i want to sketch
them at least an outline because they
provide an important indication of what
things were like in the period when
large waves of germanic migrants began
to settle in britain
namely
very unstable
at the very end of the year 406 a motley
barbarian horde of franks burgundians
and vandals
took advantage of an exceptionally cold
winter
crossed the frozen rhine and rampaged
throughout gaul
in response a roman general in britain
named constantius was raised to the
purple as constantine iii and departed
for gaul stripping the province of its
legions in order to respond to the
frankish threat
in 410
the leaders of the romano-british
community tired of being left
defenseless
expelled the remaining officials of this
usurping emperor they then appealed
directly to the emperor onorius for help
they were initially met with silence
understandable perhaps
as rome had been sacked that year by the
visigoths
the following year 411 we have a curious
text called the rescript of onorius
in which the emperor tells the cities of
britain to
look to their own defenses
there is some dispute about whether this
document refers to roman britain
or to the cities of brutium in southern
italy
we don't have a mention of this document
until the 6th century
but if it did apply to britain
then it represents the last official
communication that we know of between
britain and the roman empire
but regardless we can be sure that the
roman empire was disconnected from
britain from this point on
and it must have been rough
one of our most vivid sources for this
period is a text called on the ruin and
conquest of britain by the romano
british monk gildas
jonas is one of the most important
sources we have for this period
he was one of the few who thought to
record the decline of roman britain and
the arrival of the germanic peoples
but gildas was writing over a hundred
years after the events he describes
so it's not always clear what his
sources are nevertheless he records that
the romano british authorities wrote to
the imperial government and begged for
help
this appeal is dated to between 446 and
454 a.d
and it was addressed to the roman
general flavius edius
according to gildas it read
two edius thrice consul the groans of
the britons
the barbarians drive us to the sea
the sea drives us to the barbarians
between these two means of death
we are either killed
or drowned
there was no reply
so what are we to make of britain in the
late 4th and early 5th centuries
it was on the decline economically
its horizons had shrunk in every way
and it was increasingly subject to
incursions from overseas
some were warlike others fairly peaceful
but regardless
the door
was open